What is the type of
this quadrilateral?
Be as specific as possible
with the given data.
So it clearly is
a quadrilateral.
We have four sides here.
And we see that we have two
pairs of parallel sides.
Or we could also say there are
two pairs of congruent sides
here as well.
This side is parallel and
congruent to this side.
congruent to that side.
So we're dealing
with a parallelogram.
Let's do more of these.
So here it looks like
a same type of scenario
we just saw in the last one.
We have two pairs of
parallel and congruent sides,
but all the sides aren't
equal to each other.
If they're all
equal to each other,
we'd be dealing with a rhombus.
But here, they're not
all equal to each other.
This side is congruent
to the side opposite.
That's another parallelogram.
Now this is interesting.
We have two pairs of sides that
are parallel to each other,
but now all the sides
have an equal length.
So this would be
a parallelogram.
And it is a
parallelogram, but they're
saying to be as specific as
possible with the given data.
So saying it's a
rhombus would be
more specific than saying
it's a parallelogram.
This does satisfy
the constraints
for being a parallelogram,
but saying it's a rhombus
tells us even more.
Not every parallelogram
is a rhombus,
but every rhombus
is a parallelogram.
Here, they have the sides are
parallel to the side opposite
and all of the sides are equal.
Let's do a few more of these.
What is the type of
this quadrilateral?
Be as specific as possible
with the given data .
So we have two pairs of
sides that are parallel,
or I should say one pair.
We have a pair of sides
that are parallel.
And then we have another
pair of sides that are not.
So this is a trapezoid.
But then they have
two choices here.
They have trapezoid and
isosceles trapezoid.
Now an isosceles
trapezoid is a trapezoid
where the two non-parallel
sides have the same length, just
like an isosceles
triangle, you have
two sides have the same length.
Well we could see these two
non-parallel sides do not
have the same length.
So this is not an
isosceles trapezoid.
If they did have the
same length, then
we would pick that
because that would
be more specific
than just trapezoid.
But this case right over here,
this is just a trapezoid.
Let's do one more of these.
What is the type of
this quadrilateral?
Well we could say
it's a parallelogram
because all of the
sides are parallel.
But if we wanted to
be more specific,
you could also see that
all the sides are the same.
So you could say it's
a rhombus, but you
could get even more
specific than that.
You notice that
all the sides are
intersecting at right angles.
So this is-- if we wanted to be
as specific as possible-- this
is a square.
Let me check the answer.
Got it right.